what is happening
oh
you just spit them out
What's the title of Savannah Chrisley's
latest Adventure in parenting I come to
so many realizations well she dubs this
moment with sister Chloe trying to get
her to wear a retainer
what is wrong with you
yeah there's been some dance parties
dressing room antics you need to wear a
bra with it what
did and now in Savannah's newest
Instagram story even the pair's
nighttime rituals are bringing the LOLs
what is happening
what
you just spit them out
I had to slurp but
I should tell you how it is I don't
think she was like I don't like that I
was like gosh this is a little harsh
for fans of Chrisley Knows Best
Savannah's reaction might seem familiar
before you always wanted to clear to my
mouth
for years remember when Todd watched
Grayson get braces so now I'm going to
put the key in that little hole and then
what you'll do is you'll just turn it
backwards like that now do you go this
way or this way oh my God you didn't
listen up
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
let's do that noise
you just spit them out yeah those two
need a good crack up now and then the
family's legal battle it's no laughing
matter I'm helping to raise my 10 year
old sister and 16 year old brother what
we will not do is we will not break
Todd and Julie began their combined
19-year prison sentence in January
leaving Savannah to parent Chloe and
Grayson I think it's probably the best
that Chloe be allowed to grow up as any
other 10 year old would be a 10 year old
is hard no matter what circumstances are
with Chloe and Grayson I'm like you know
what they need to see peace and calmness
because I'm not their mom I'm not their
dad I'm I'm their sister if Todd and
Julie could share a message with the
world what do you think they'd want them
to know I think they'd want folks to
know that they are the same people
they've always been that they didn't do
these things and that they're going to
fight to get their name cleared any
family who faces a loved one going to
prison
um it's a very difficult challenge but
they're strong they're faithful we need
to figure out healthier ways to cope
with things and one of those ways
turning this bedtime chore into a giggle
fit
it's hard
I had to slurp but
[Music]